the time is
3:19 we also need to pass our exams
London
[Music]
I good morning the time is
so I've been just doing some practice
questions on Nephrology or kidney
medicine because one of the biggest
exams of my final year of medical school
is coming up this month and you best
believe nephology doesn't come to me
easily so I deal with my weakest
subjects firsts thing in the morning
because early mornings are the times
where I can personally deep focus the
best also as always I start my exam
preparation with planning and during
planning again I focus on my weaknesses
realizing I don't need to put much
effort into one subject instead I
allocate that extra time into the other
subject where I struggle for example I
aim for 50 practice questions plus slash
cards for each topic but for nephology I
might double that so hopefully I can get
to a point where I'm good at all of the
topics to optimize my exam
[Music]
results we did a quick change of scor
because we can I'm in the study pod
right outside of my room correction my
sister's room because currently I'm at
her student accommodation in London so
it's quite nice it's tailored for
students and during my breaks I can go
outside and enjoy London now let's get
on with today's to-do
[Music]
list
right let's get dressed to see the
London I no
London Bridge no London well all of that
including the Big
[Music]
Ben
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way my sister is a medical
student as well and this is the hospital
she has her placement at and that's the
Big Ben how cool is
[Music]
that this is London ey and it's so empty
I've been here during the day and it was
full of people perks of coming to
touristic places early in the morning
you get to see the beautiful sunrise and
there's few people to get in your
[Music]
photos okay here's our spot and I'm
going to test myself with some flash
cards and enjoy the V I also brought a
plastic bag with me just in case because
you know sitting on benches in London or
anywhere in the UK can get your bottom
wet because it rains a
lot so this should do the
trick
[Music]
eight rings for
8:00 we're here here to have our second
breakfast the place just opened now but
it already looks packed so hopefully
that means the food is
good you don't that's right I'll wait 10
minutes thank you I've decided to sit
outside so I can eat sooner I'm
starving you ready for can I get the
vegetarian English breakfast how would
you like actually be poach
please
I usually never order English breakfast
when I'm out eating but since we're
playing Taurus I thought I might as well
go for the full English experience I
also squeeze in a few more flash cards
but not going to lie I get distracted
very easily so not all study techniques
work well Outdoors for me like I can't
really write an essay or test myself
with long practice questions but quick
flash cards or voice notes work well for
me
okay I found a study room because now I
have an online language class to attend
on lingoda I'm learning French this has
been one of my New Year's resolutions
for a long time by the way I'm just a
beginner so pardon my French and please
don't judge my
accent bonjo this is my first class I
actually nothing if you don't understand
something just so my goal is to take one
class per week so I have a good
understanding of French by the end of
summer just in time for my trip to Paris
lingoda has classes available 24/7 and
the teachers get you speaking French
right from the
start they doing a language Sprint which
is a two-month intensive learning
challenge you get the option to do a
Sprint or a super Sprint and if you
attend all of your classes you get a 50%
cash back join the lingo to Sprint to
level up your language skills you can
use my link for 30% off or my disc
discount code zil hard 20 for an
additional €20 off okay let's explore
the
[Music]
liary second
[Applause]
[Music]
flooring
the exam I'm preparing for has 200
multiple choice questions covering all
the topics in medicine like surgery
Dermatology Cardiology everything when
I'm getting tested on such broad
material honestly I don't always have
time to read up on all the content first
but I always make sure to do lots of
practice questions because exams aren't
testing our knowledge but it's testing
how well we can apply that knowledge in
questions or in an essay whatever the
style of our assessment is so I find it
helpful to do just lots of questions and
when I get the answer wrong or I'm
unsure about something then I spend more
time to understand it and fit it into
the bigger picture for that subject the
strategy saves me so much time and I
know it might be controversial in an
Ideal World we' study for the sake of
knowledge but we also need to pass our
exams so I'm having to adapt to the
system until it
[Music]
changes
finally for break time I'm meeting a
friend this is your reminder to please
reward yourself for your efforts I know
it might feel like you haven't completed
every task yet or achieved every goal
right away but we've done our best so
give yourself a pat on the back and for
long-term success we need to enjoy the
journey to maintain this and come back
with a refresh
Focus
I call that I always Mis judge how full
the branches are when I walk to problems
I
guess huh what do you want to get um one
of us should get a curry the other one
should
get uh chicken you have mango sticky
[Music]
R do you want to swap
now
yeah
[Music]
you want anything else uh no that's all
thank
you can you do it because my hand is
hurting honestly my hand is hurting from
carrying the camera all day long which
is really weird I didn't realize
vloggers
get yeah the struggles of
[Music]
vloggers
my
ends all right let's go let's go I'm
getting how are you feeling feel okay be
honest feel pretty anxious why you're
walking in there with a huge ass camera
I know I know but yeah I don't know how
I do this yeah I really don't know do
you seeing some of her filming and where
she does it I will get so much Social
Anxiety I do get anxiety I'm just trying
to trying to hide it all right let's
let's
do it's like a sugar
jelly try it okay can we get that one as
well
oh yeah I I
want how you do it maximize flavor stir
fry
[Music]
so excuse me did you choke on the powder
y maybe show me with it yeah I think
people are more interested in the food
thanks this is the last piece actually
can I eat it yeah I need to choke on
[Music]
it